wir wollen halt nichts überstürzen mit
einverständnis was bringt uns das
einfach ohne sinn und verstand
loszulaufen und dann festzustellen wir
stehen das sackgasse und fange wieder
ganz von vorne an
genauso bei schule kita erst der öffnung
schritt nächste woche nicht schon diese
oder vor zwei wochen manch handeln ganz
ganz sensibel nur die grundschule oder
abschlussklassen braunes unter nur bei
der bestimmen inzidenz und dann auch nur
im wechsel unterrichtet eins nach dem
anderen ab regen balance muss stimmen
schule ist nämlich teil der pandemie hat
auch geholfen dass wir schulen und kitas
geschlossen haben sondern ein
bestandteil der ganzen maßnahmen und ich
möchte dass schule ist einfach so ein
versuchslabor des ideologischen gründen
weil manche sagen der schule kann nichts
passieren ist alles widerlegt worden
da gibt studien vom juli letzten jahres
ist das nichts in der schule passiert
dollet etr gab es auch kaum infektion
aber jetzt haben wir gesehen dass das so
ist und deswegen ja langsamer staat aber
mit entsprechenden test konzepten und
mit einem masten konzert auch das ist
wichtig aber wir blenden das thema
schule und jugend nicht aus ich will es
noch mal sagen
auf der einen seite jetzt daran dass wir
wirklich gute bildungsabschlüsse
erreichen
wir sind so stolz auf bayrische
abschlüsse als bayerische abitur auf die
mittlere reife den abschluss nach der
mittelschule oder auch beispielsweise
die beruflichen abschlüsse ich glaube
schon dass wir sagen können wir liegen
da ziemlich gut in deutschland das soll
ja man nicht überhören und sagen wir
sind die besten aber naja vielleicht
doch aber wichtig ist dabei dass wir
diese qualität erreichen
aber jetzt nicht irgendwen noten jagd
machen oder leistungsdruck xxl nach dem
motto zwei monate ausgefallene zu finden
ist einfach nach anpassen kluge konzepte
moderne pädagogik das ist nämlich aber
umgekehrt genauso ab jetzt linke fordern
schulnoten ganz abzuschaffen ein ganzes
jahr einfach zu speichern zu wiederholen
es wäre so was von unfair gegenüber
jungen menschen und das werden wir nicht
tun
und eins ist für mich wichtig wir
brauchen noch eine sonder unterstützung
und zwar für diejenigen kinder und
schüler die mit der pandemie nicht so
zurecht kommen
schulisch gesehen
aus ferneren familien vielleicht auch
mit migrationshintergrund oder die
einfach die psychische belastung
schwerer verkraften
wo die familie ist nicht so auffallen
kann das will ich zur chefsache machen
dieses thema will ich zur chefsache
machen einen kindergipfel auf den weg
bringen wo wir uns dann genau damit
beschäftigen und wo wir mit den
zuständigen stellen darüber reden wie
sind die folgen dieser generation wie
können wir sie unterstützen wirtschaft
mittelstand nächster punkt auch da
schritt für schritt werden die friseure
als ersten schritt geöffnet ist es
wirklich angemessen was man dafür
spricht darüber macht jeder macht sich
lächerlich über friseure
mal abgesehen davon das ist ein sehr
gutes handwerk ist für die einen sagen
das ist nur mode okay sei da nicht
wichtig haar schneiden wir diskutieren
ist im kabinett auch immer albert bürger
hält das thema für übertrieben
hubert aiwanger sagte es ist eigentlich
egal
ich habe verständnis dafür dass auch ja
jeweils wenn man hinschaut
aber das ist nicht ganz so wichtig
übrigens meine haare wachsen auch
unendlich wird man übrigens mal
interessieren vielleicht könnt ihr mal
eine resonanz geben sondern dass er
länger lassen also bis auf die furcht
bankrott retten sollen länger lassen
oder lieber wieder kürzer feedback wer
ganz spannend aber ist das das
entscheidende
ich habe briefe von älteren menschen
erreicht sie sagen sie können sich nicht
mehr selbst zum beispiel die haare
waschen pflegen und sie möchten nach
zehn wochen wieder hygiene haben ist
doch verständlich
wo ich erzähle ich noch eine andere
geschichte wo es um würde geht
meine mutter ist 1994 verstorben
am vierten september am 12 august 1994
hat er mein vater geburtstag das war das
letzte mal dass wir den zusammen
gefeiert haben zu der zeit war meine
mutter schon im krankenhaus und mein
vater kam dann mit dazu und das
wichtigste war für meine mutter dass an
seinem geburtstag den wir in der
krankenhaus kathi nürnberger südklinikum
begangen haben ganz klein bisschen
kaffee und kuchen eine katze öffentlich
dass sie sich für ihren mann hat schön
machen würden und der krankenhaus flüsse
hatte ganze arbeit geleistet und ich
weiß noch nicht stolz und glücklich sie
war das sind
nichts ist so unfair wenn man das jetzt
niedermacht oder schlecht redet ab
erster märz ist es wieder soweit wenn
die zahlen besser sind ich kann mir
anfang märz dann vorstellen wenn die
zahlen so bleiben
das nächste ist dann die gärtnereien
folgen weil es ist ähnlich wie
supermärkte auch zum teil verderbliche
ware ist passt auch in die frühjahrszeit
hinein
das kann man gut organisiert zum
einzelhändler von dem desaster bei den
hilfen habe ich gesprochen aber das geld
wird kommen da bin ich ganz sicher ich
hoffe so schnell wie möglich jetzt geht
es um perspektiven
natürlich wird der einzelne nicht ewig
zu sein ist doch ganz klar es gibt ja
auch tolle schutzkonzept mit sp2 masse
aber auch hier müssen die zahlen stimmen
und die zahl die wir hier alle
angepeilten ist die 35 übrigens letztes
jahr
letztes jahr waren die zahlen deutlich
niedriger landesweit als begegnet haben
ich bin sicher wenn wir die 35 haben
dann wird der einzelhandel wenn sich das
etwas stabilisiert geöffnet werden
können vielleicht sogar schon ab mitte
märz nach der mpk und das wichtig ist
aber auch in vorsichtiger form man kann
anfangen mit click and needs ein konzept
mit der mit der regulation der
quadratmeterzahl und ich sage auch sehr
deutlich es muss natürlich auch regional
ausgesteuert werden
ich kann ja schlecht jemand erklären die
rheinländer aus mit einer ganz niedrigen
incidents warum er wegen dem hotspot
tirschenreuth jetzt nicht seine
geschäfte und seine existenz führen darf
natürlich muss es das geben und ich sage
es auch mal ganz deutlich und ein
bisschen müssen jetzt noch mal
nachsteuern ist bin ich auch an den
wirtschaftsministerium das die
discounter und supermärkte nicht den
einzelhändlern schon dadurch das
geschäft kaputt machen indem sie einfach
sortiment für alle anbieten wenn dies
mit dem handel klappt dann auch für
individualsport wie tennis oder golf das
alles kommt mit zusammen und das
ähnliche gilt dann übrigens für die
kultur weil wir auch kultur an der
stelle stärken wollen
hab das schon im landtag gesagt sagte es
hier sorry letztes jahr ist es ein
fehler gewesen zu sagen diese kultur sei
nicht systemrelevant sie ist es
natürlich das spüren wir während des 4
und deswegen werden wir auch mit den
programmen daran arbeiten gerade die
nächsten zwei jahre bei kultur den
schwerpunkt in die menschen und die
künstlerin und künstler zu setzen und
weniger in steine und bauten im moment
sind die menschen und die künstliche
aktivität die kreativität der künstler
kunst schaffenden wichtig deswegen ist
wichtig nicht nur hochkultur zu fördern
freie szene junge künstler und künstler
unter concept aufzulegen von einer ganz
modernen openair kulturen ganz bayern wo
wir alle plätze und bereiche zur
verfügung stellen letzter punkt die
gastro ist am schwersten
weil hier die schutzkonzepte schwierig
sind
deswegen müssen da die zahlen noch etwas
stabiler und besser werden wenn der gast
touristisch schwerer mit ft2 allein zu
erklären wenn dann acht pumpels
beieinander sitzen ohne maske dann
könnte es noch gefährlicher werden
möchte ich eine prognose für ostern
abgeben
das ist damals nächste woche ist ich
würde nichts ausschließen aber auch
jetzt nichts zu sagen
vor sieben wochen war alles total
schwierig da haben wir gedacht land
unter in sechs wochen glaube ich
ungefähr es ostern wer weiß wie sich das
entwickelt es gibt hoffnung wie gesagt
und es gibt auch linien dem man
hochrechnen kann aber ob es so bleibt
ich bleibe lieber im team vorsichtig
will die menschen jetzt nicht verbrennen
und wieder enttäuschen
das schlimmste was ich in diesen zeiten
erlebe ist enttäuschte hoffnung lieber
seriös und fachlich bleiben es ist auch
leichter das gebe ich zu wenn man das
gegenteil macht manche versprechen das
blaue vom himmel runter
manche fordern des wassers kommt es
übrigens beeindrucken stimme also wenn
wir sagen wir beschließen am mittwoch
eine eröffnung und dann am montag zu
fordern und sagen ich schätze dass
dadurch die sinne sowie im hochsommer zu
sagen morgen muss die sonne scheinen und
einer nächstes ist ich hab's durchsetzt
bitte das dürfen alle übrigens aber
nicht ich und wir wir haben die
letztverantwortung wir müssen unsere
verantwortung gerecht werden so schwer
es manchmal chat wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren